Oh, okay. What do you think people
gossip behind your back? They want you
to push certain agendas and sometimes
it's linked to money.
>> How many children does he have? One. But
that doesn't make sense from a Darwinian
point of view.
>> Actually get dopamine rush when I'm
going to Fridays and Sundays. I get
excitement, bro. It's like I'm newly
red.
>> I'm lucky. I can't wait to meet her.
>> You know, the da becomes like like your
father figure. Adam and Islam evolved
from other chimpanzeee like creatures. I
believe that I cannot accept kafir
atheists being more confident than a
believer and that makes me angry. If you
were to live at the time of dal and came
face to face with him, what is one thing
you would tell him? What is the most
demonic thought that you're afraid to
talk about? My father wanted to spend
more time with me. He rang me. I was at
university. I mean, I said, "Oh, I'm I'm
like I'm busy now or something, right?"
And then that was my last phone call.
Let's play a game.
>> Asalam allayikum to brothers and sisters
and dear friends. Hope you guys are
well. Inshallah. Welcome to another
episode of Let's Play a Game.
Alhamdulillah, we have brother Sam Ahmed
here and brother says he's an amazing
person. Alhamdulillah has done amazing
works. But we want to know our guests a
bit more personal and that's what makes
this show exciting, a little bit on the
edge and a little bit sinister. So we
have five cards here. One of these cards
from sisters is the white card with a
question mark which is the general
questions. The red cards with a heart
and a lock is more personal questions
and borderline edgy. The golden cards
with the rings is pertaining to
marriage. The cards that are black with
a key symbol on it is pertaining to the
unseen dal nightmares um magic all that
kind of stuff. Subhan Allah. And then we
have the sodaka cards. When I give these
cards to him, our guest has a choice of
forgoing four cards he does not feel
comfortable answering. However, there's
a little catch to that we will come to
later. But let's introduce our guest
inhalamkum.
Salam.
>> How you doing?
>> Okay.
>> Alhamdulillah. I'm actually very
excited. You know why? Because yes,
we're friends, we know each other, etc.
But when we're in the car, I'm not going
to come and start asking you random
questions about your personal life.
Okay? But in this show, it does bring
that part out in a way that's halal. Of
course, we're not here to, you know, go
into territories that we shouldn't go to
because, you know, we don't want to get
a punch from you. So, we're going to
start the show. Inshallah. Is there any
questions that you like to ask?
Uh, what's the first? No, I'm good.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay, good. So, I'm
going to give out the cards in one by
one.
>> You have this card holder in front of
you. You can put them however you like,
inshallah. Once you want to ask the uh
the question, you will slide one of the
cards to me. I will read the card out
myself. Yes, I have the pleasure of
doing that. And like I said before in
the show, you have four cards that you
can forgo. You don't want to answer it.
You put it face down. Out of those four
cards, you do have to reveal one. If
there's any question there, you're like,
I do not want to answer this at all. you
go to the saddaka card as an option one
inshallah. So we'll get into the show in
it will be self-explanatory. So let's
start off with the white cards. These
are the generic questions. Okay. You
seem a bit nervous. Are you okay?
>> Uh yeah. Okay.
>> Yeah. I've [laughter] never done
anything like this before.
>> We used to talk about this show. Do you
remember? A long time ago. Yeah. And now
I'm in the hot seat.
>> Seven.
>> So I've given the cards out, guys. I've
given them eight of the white cards, the
generic questions, 10 of the personal
cards, four of the cards pertaining to
marriage, and four of the cards
pertaining to the unseen.
What's the official reaction? Are you
okay? What's going on?
>> These questions are tough. He's he's
sweating. Are you okay?
>> I I thought a few of them were going to
be tough. A lot of them are tough.
>> Is it?
>> Yeah.
>> Do you want water?
>> No, I'm good.
>> Yeah. Even if you said yes, we can't
give you one. [laughter]
>> Okay, good. So now it is totally up to
you.
>> It's really well thought out, by the
way.
>> Alhamdulillah. Thanks to the man.
>> I just don't want to be on here again.
[laughter]
>> We don't need to come again after this.
I don't want to come again.
>> Okay, so it's up to you. I don't know if
you're the type that eats his burger
first or his chips. So, you know, do you
want to go through the easy ones first?
Okay.
>> So, it's totally up to you. Whichever
one you just slide it to inshallah and
then um Oh, he's going for the red card.
Oh, he's he's he's he's a bit risky.
>> Uh I think
>> Oh, that's a tough one.
>> All right, let's go with something easy.
>> Okay, good. Okay, let's see. So, it's
the first card is a white card,
inshallah.
Okay, that's why I love this show. Okay.
What do you wish people asked you more
about?
I think we have all done saras of water
wells, massaged orphans. But this is the
new in town guys. Teaching someone how
to pray salah, how to do wudoo, learning
surah faty that for the rest of their
life from sisters that every action they
do in salah to wood to to reciting surah
fata is on your scales. You want to
teach someone how to pray salah, we do
that, brothers and sisters. Go to the
link and a£100 can teach 20 to 60 people
to learn how to pray salah. Imagine the
rewards in the hereafter. Go to the link
and donate now. And now back to the
podcast. History is one of those things
that people don't really ask about. So
for example,
>> all right, we're discussing evolution,
we're discussing atheism, blah blah
blah. Okay, but what's the history of
atheism in the Muslim world? What
happened in Central Asia? What happened
in the Soviet Union? what happened in
all these different parts of the world
which are now very much secular but were
ruled by colonial powers. So a lot of as
you know what I do is work on atheism,
Darwinism, scientism but it's the
history of it.
>> People aren't really interested in
history. That's true. And when you speak
to them about, for example, um you
mentioned certain things about Neville
Chamberlain,
>> what happened before Churchill took
over, uh Julian Huxley, his link to
UNESCO, all these types of things.
People aren't interested in that.
>> What's UNESCO?
>> United Nations Educational Scientific
and Cultural Organization. So this was
set up by
>> Can I just say mashallah? Wow. I tested
you there. Yes. Wow. Mah fantastic.
>> Uh people like Julian Huxley. Dangerous
people. Very dangerous Darwinist, right?
But people generally are just interested
in oh where does this fossil fit?
>> I want to know about like okay I want
people to ask me about that. That's deep
you know because if you go to the root
of it it's more important because it can
dissect a lot of things like they say
the one who forgets his past will never
know his future. Absolutely. So it's
it's very very important. That's
interesting. It's just an interesting
take. Subhan Allah. Okay.
>> All right. Am I doing another one now?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> You know what we should do? We should
get like a heart palpetation measurement
like just to see like your heart rate as
each question [laughter]
as heart rate is 70 80 per minute.
>> Oo,
>> you've been sticking on that card for a
long time. Is that the same card?
>> Yeah,
>> I'm really intrigued by it's one of
those it's one of those cards I'm
thinking about.
>> But the audience is excited as well.
They can't see your cards.
>> They can't. They can't.
>> Uh yeah, I'll go with this one.
>> Okay. This is the first personal card
that he is
>> asking. Yeah. Oh, okay.
>> That's a tough one.
>> Is it?
>> Yeah.
>> You could have forgot it.
>> But you know, sometimes, you know, I
believe in eating the frog.
>> Yeah. Nice. Why a frog?
>> You There's a book called There's a book
called Eat That Frog, right? It's like
you do the hardest task first. You know,
I'm like that cuz you know why Allah
says in the Quran,
with hardship comes ease. Verily, with
hardship comes ease. The opposite is
true. Because if with hardship comes
ease, with ease comes hardship. M
>> so sometimes when you get the hardship
out the way you have ease in the long
run
>> so people like please tell us okay who
do you wish would forgive you
>> I think my father
>> okay
>> um I had a like my father wanted to
spend more time with me
>> and I was like doing my thing young
person
>> okay
>> uh I remember one time he rang me I was
at university and I was just I was just
with my friend and he was speaking to me
and he rang me from Pakistan. I was at
university at the time and I said, "Oh,
I'm I'm like I'm busy now or something,
right?"
>> And then that was my last phone call
>> and he died after that. So
>> he he was one of those dads that really
wanted to spend time with me, but I just
wanted to do my own thing, that kind of
thing.
>> Uh I had a good relationship with him,
but he died when I was at university. I
was around 21 years old. So,
>> it's one of those things that I spoke to
my mom about and my mom said, "No, no,
he wasn't, you know, upset with you."
But in my heart, I think
>> last phone call
like, "Yeah, subhan Allah." It's like if
you look at the of Allah, there's things
that happen. Subhan, we don't know. But
I'll be honest with you. I mean, if I
met your dad, I would say, "Please give
me the secret of how you've brought a
son like this." Like, I'll be honest
with you. I would say to him, "Please,
what's the recipe of having a son like
you?" Because at the end of the day,
alhamdulillah, look, you know, I've
known you for about what good 12, 13
years. Alhamdulillah. You know, I and we
know I know people I can get home with,
if I don't get with and even the people
I don't get on with, I'll meet them for
the sake of Allah. Do you get it? Just
cuz at the end of the day, you know, one
of the people under the shade of Allah
are those who met each other purely for
the sake of Allah, you know. So,
>> forgiving people is a big thing.
>> It is it is it is a big thing. It is a
big thing. And I think your dad would be
proud of you, you know. Subhan Allah.
And
>> there is that. Well, look, you know,
there is, you know, that you haven't
like been there. Like my father was a
person who really uh taught he taught me
public speaking
>> like not formally but he wanted me to be
a public speaker. He got me to do like a
speech.
>> Uh he got me into martial arts. He gave
me a lot of confidence. But one of those
things I only appreciated my father
after a long time after he was gone.
When he was alive, especially the last
couple of years, I didn't really
appreciate him.
>> And that's why, you know, that thing
about forgiveness because
>> I didn't spend time with him. I didn't
really, it's not like I was a bad son,
but
>> you know, like when a father wants to
spend time with the child and the
child's just like, "Yeah, I just want to
hang out with my friends. I just want to
do this. I want to do that." He used to
talk to me about certain things. used to
say, you know, I want you to do this.
You should be doing this and you know
the usual type of thing.
>> So that's one of those things that that
last phone call and I don't talk about
this ever,
>> but that last phone call just killed me
>> cuz the next thing he was
>> he was not alive after that.
>> He had a heart attack. Next time I spoke
to him uh in the hospital, he couldn't
actually speak.
>> He's actually completely uh bedridden.
And that was just a few weeks before he
died. So, but if 100% so deep, but you
know, if you think about it, that's
something that you would do anything to
have, right?
>> Imagine how it's going to be in Jenna
when you see him
>> in
>> cuz cuz you know it's something that you
really want inshallah and may Allah
reunite you guys.
>> And I just want to share something that
um we don't appreciate people in our
lives until they're gone.
>> Exactly.
>> And the second thing which is important
is uh my mom said this to me. She said
after my dad died that now you'll know
who your friends are.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And that stuck with me. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
>> That is deep, man. Wow. And and wow, we
appreciate it makes me appreciate even
more. May Allah bless and preserve.
>> Deep question. Deep question. Subhan
Allah. And that's what the whole point
of the show is about sisters to get, you
know, it's like um you know, I can
remember once I was in speaker. I was
with a this this guy who was really
hostile towards me. Yeah. And one day, I
think I just done a video about my kids
or something and he was like, "You know
what, Ali, when I watched that video,
you became human in my eyes." He goes
before he was just Ali Daw who comes
speaking in debates. But he goes it
melted my heart. It's like when we do
this it's just the people to be like
there's a Ahmed there's Ali there going
to be Roberts here is going to be coming
here Mhammed's going to come here. This
is a side to us you don't know you know
just on that point um I was with someone
just a few days ago and uh funny enough
I rang you and we spoke about something
and then somebody in my family said I
wish you weren't friends with this guy.
And I said, "Yeah,
>> so [laughter] so so I was like, you
know, all this negativity from Tik Tok